black people can't carve pumpkins
apparently this is what i have learned
from a school in seattle the school in
seattle has an annual pumpkin parade
that's a sweet thing to do isn't that
nice little kids go around they've got
their pumpkins they carve that's a nice
little fall
halloween tradition or at least it was
at benjamin franklin elementary school
but you see that school's racial equity
team why does it have a rate i don't
know but they have a racial equity team
this is one of the consequences of
critical race theory and this is one of
the effects of that you see in the world
this critical race theory that begins in
law schools and then permeates our legal
and academic systems to the point that
you have racial equity teams in
elementary schools and to the point that
they cancel pumpkin parades apparently
quote
historically the pumpkin parade
marginalizes students of color who do
not celebrate the holiday
specifically these students have
requested to be isolated on campus while
the event took place
this according to a spokesman from the
school talking to our friend jason rands
who's a radio host in seattle
the students are like six right so this
we are being told that
and i don't even believe that this is
true but let's just say that it is true
that a six-year-old didn't want to
participate in the school activity we
are being told that is basically the
equivalent of a of a bus boycott
we're told this is basically the
equivalent of the civil rights marches
the march on washington because you see
black people they don't have halloween
that's a white person holiday they don't
have the fall
that the fall is a white person season
what is a black person season i have no
idea
i it seems to me it's pretty
counterproductive to character black
people in this way
as if black people can't can't carve the
pumpkins it actually reminds me of
something that i noticed in college
so i'm in college not that long ago what
was it like 10 years ago less
and i'm in college and
it was martin luther king day
very very liberal liberal college and
they served a special meal in the dining
halls they served barack obama's
favorite fried chicken recipe
and they served a bunch of other
food that's mostly southern food that we
traditionally associate with black
people watermelon that sort of thing
and i i looked at that and i thought
hold on so martin luther king day
on martin luther king day you you have
barack obama's favorite fried chicken
wrist because obama and martin luther
king are both black so that makes total
sense
and obama because he's a black guy man
he loves his fried chicken isn't that
right
i doubt that he does i suspect that
barack obama probably prefers mahi-mahi
or something because he grew up in
hawaii and he was raised almost
exclusively by white people and it's
this ridiculous caricature to pretend
that because barack obama's black what
he drinks grape soda or something and he
no because
at these very liberal enlightened
institutions
everyone's got to fit in their little
box and only white people do this and
only black people do this and apparently
this is going all the way down to this
very woke elementary school where the
black kids can't carve the pumpkins i'm
so glad you liked that clip head on over
get the full show you can do it here on
youtube subscribe ring the bell and
go subscribe to the michael knowles show
podcast m-i-c-h-a-e-l-w-l-e-s
s-h-o-w you can subscribe for free apple
podcast stitcher spotify google play
wherever you get your podcasts we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]